okay not a mata mata not asleeping
not like that passing out the mapa
[Music]
alright y'all so as you might have heard
one of my main goals this year and every
year if tiller in Spanish we do speak
quite fast but you're good and you can
roll your R's I'm impressed
well I grew up seeing classified I grew
up actually seen languages so right yes
so I can I can adapt really well but I
have to have somebody do it in order to
just come here I'll be there whatever
you alright don't you threaten me and
even though I've spent countless out
horse on language ABB's there's no
better way to dive right into a language
than to speak it with a pro so today I
have a special guest one of our
producers from the show named teaser viv
Anna would it be say sorry sisse Rivera
okay so do you is Spanish your first
language a second or so I learned
Spanish in English simultaneously
English kind of one but I know enough to
be able to translate for my parents
because they're both immigrated here so
yeah been my you know my job alright so
what are we doing today so I'm going to
give you a pop quiz using your very own
pop songs oh yes so you're gonna have to
figure out if you know your music in
espanol
okay it's been your
number one yeah desde que te fuiste z--
eddo respira
por la primera vez sig waddleon t see
first time first time you said pretty
since you've been gone
yes Pilar sorry por primera vez pero ESO
por PS a-- l mere echo ho del P so don't
abandon Asus las cosas yes what PS a--
baby yes I thought you for some reason I
thought piano it was but it's not fatal
but oh okay I was like wait but that
doesn't start with peas but you know
what yeah I got it you got it okay
all right next one okay this one I think
you'll do really good okay necesito mas
que lo TT Corino as messantia the deal
for safari no no there are mucho calor
no color color harpy tongue I don't know
I need more heat from your baby oh this
one will be good okay lo que no te mata
the hace must worth it
okay okay not the Mata
Martha Martha sleeping not like that
passing out stronger yes what does the
gaming charter have the charade this is
charades okay mata Mata kill kill Lord
MOT today teach me kill on duolingo or
Ravenna strong yet you're not there yet
yeah okay okay this one okay so una more
fun suave
nothing yeah yeah I got it I gotta see
him oh it's perfect en a un lado okay
screw me amaz with this I'm a flow media
dark side
yeah and I was like not even the line it
was like getting to it
[Music]
you did better than I did trying to
translate the songs how about that
this hey DZ especially cuz your music is
so poetic it's like things are
translated I was right am i right yes
yeah so it's not it isn't as easy as
just like it back it up no and I know it
like dancing everything I don't get it
work on it yeah like a lot more now
sometime next time yes until next time
thank you bye adios on some banana or
hasta luego
absolutely yeah whatever subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going